what we are going to do in this video is
talk a little bit about experiments in
science and experiments are really the
heart of all scientific progress if you
think about let's just say this
represents just baseline knowledge and
then people have hunches in the world
and for a lot of times people say hey i
have a hunch that that thing is good for
you or that thing is good for you but
they really had no way of of measuring
how confident they were there were no
they really had no good way of proving
it and even more because they had no
good way of proving it it was hard for
people to build on top of that knowledge
but with the scientific method and
experiments people were able to say hey
we have a hypothesis here and we were
able to do some well-designed
experiments and so we feel pretty good
that this is true and then future people
are going to say hey since we feel
pretty good that this is true maybe we
can design an experiment to see whether
that is true hey that actually is true
and then they can build on that and we
end up having scientific progress that
can accumulate over hundreds of years
and this is really important that the
experiments are well designed because in
the future and this happens all the time
we might realize that hey actually there
was a little a few assumptions baked in
here that weren't accurate that allowed
us to make
essentially misleading conclusions so
our conclusion wasn't quite right there
and then we'll have to rebuild from that
point in order to make sure that we are
truly making progress so the key
question is how do we set up
well-designed experiments and it's a
whole field of study but the whole port
of this video is to really give an
introduction to it
so let's just start with a hypothesis
let's say that you have a hypothesis
that some
pill
that is made up of the the petals of
some flower
that this pill right over here it
improves
it improves
running
running
speed
it improves running speed if someone
were to take it
so the important thing of any hypothesis
it has to be testable and so what you do
is you have to think well how am i going
to test it well what you can do so how
are you going to test your hypothesis at
first you might say give the bill so
give the pill to
some
some runners
to some runners and test their time
test their 100 meter time
test
their
100
meter time
before the pill
before
the pill
and after
and you might say hey maybe if you know
i don't know their times improve after
maybe my hypothesis is correct pause
this video and see if you feel
comfortable with with this test right
over here this experiment
well actually there's several problems
with this experiment how are you
selecting these runners and if you give
them the pill and their speed improves
did it truly improve because of the pill
or did it improve because of some other
thing that they are doing maybe they got
new shoes or maybe their diet improved
in some way or maybe they just had a
psychological improvement this is often
known as the placebo effect if people
are taking something that they think
will believe that they think will help
them it often will help them even if
that thing is just a just an empty
capsule or just a sugar tablet so how do
you avoid these types of errors
well what you could do is you can find
runners and put them into two groups
so
let's say this is one group right over
here and then this is another group and
what you would want to do is you'd want
to go into the population
of people
and you would want to randomly select
whether someone goes into one group or
another group
why random because if you don't randomly
select there's a chance that there might
be some implicit bias that you might
just happen to be picking people who
maybe their running speed is on an
upward trajectory and they just happen
to go into the group that will
eventually get the pill
so you randomly
randomly put them
in those groups and what you want to do
is you'll have a control group and
you'll have a group that gets your pill
and so
this group gets the pill
gets the pill
and now you might be tempted to for this
group to say well they don't get a pill
and then after a few months of it and it
should be the same amount of time you
say hey did this group's times improve
over the 100 meters how did that compare
to this group but be very careful if
this group gets the pill and this group
gets nothing then the pill might be
providing that placebo effect again that
just making people think they're getting
something that's making them faster
might actually be a self-fulfilling
prophecy so it's actually important that
you also give these people a pill
although this pill would just look like
a pill so this would be just an empty
empty
empty pill that looks the same
now there's another idea when you're
designing scientific experiments that it
needs to be double blind let me write
this down
double
blind so as you can imagine it implies
that two things are blind here so the
first thing that needs to be blind is
the people themselves should not know
which group they're getting put into
they should not know which pill they're
taking because obviously if you put
someone in this pill in this group and
you say hey you're in the control group
we're just going to give you an empty
pill well then the placebo effect might
not be in and might not work
it's also important because it's double
blind that the people who are working
with the runners the people who are
measuring them so that the researchers
right over here so i'll draw someone
with a clipboard
so the researchers who are observing
these people and maybe administering the
pill and telling them about the
experiment that they too do not know
which group they are administering it to
because if they did they might be able
to signal somehow they might be able to
even subconsciously give a sense of
which group folks are in
and so let's say we do all of these
things and so we're getting in the
direction of a well-designed experiment
and we find that the
10 people in this group versus the 10
people in this group after three months
these folks had a five percent
improvement in running speed and these
people had a 10 improvement in running
speed
is that enough to conclude that our
hypothesis is correct
well you might be tempted it seems
suggestive but that's where statistics
come into order because there's just
some random chance that you got lucky
that you happen to pick the people that
your pill does nothing but you just
happen to pick the people who are going
to improve more and there's a whole
field of inferential statistics when you
take a statistics course that will go in
more depth into this but essentially
what you're going to do is you're going
to say hey assume that your pill does
nothing what's the probability of
getting this result for 10 people
or what's the probability of getting
this difference in result
and if that probability is very low well
you say hey that would suggest that my
pill actually does do something
now another important principle of a
of an experiment like this is it needs
to be replicable
replicable
because even though you thought you did
a good job people might not want to take
your word for it and it's important in
science for people to be skeptical when
people do experiments they want to have
a result and that bias might creep in
and so if someone else does an
experiment you need to say how you did
that experiment so other people can see
if they get the same results because
even though you think you randomly
selected you might only do it with
people from a certain country or under
certain weather conditions or assuming
other constraints and then these people
might do it slightly differently or in a
different country or under different
constraints and realize that hey the
explanation for this maybe was something
else
another thing to keep in mind is the
larger your samples right over here the
larger groups that you're able to do
this with the stronger that the
statistics actually be actually become
and i would say not just larger but the
more diverse across genders across
ethnicities across geographies
so the big picture here is is all
scientific progress is based on us
designing good experiments and being
very rigorous about how we think about
those experiments and what i've
highlighted here is just the beginning
of how we might think about designing
those experiments and as you go into
your scientific careers look at other
people's experiments and see whether
they've done these things because many
times you will find that it is not as
rigorous as it might seem at first